buongiorno a tutti oggi vorrei
raccontarvi di come dei pesci dei
batteri e dei pomodori
mi hanno insegnato a sperare in un mondo
diverso e forse migliore siamo ciò che
mangiamo sosteneva firebug ogni
particella che entra all'interno del
nostro organismo tramite l'alimentazione
garantisce la nostra vita stessa
tutti noi oggi riconosciamo l'altissimo
valore delle nostre scelte a tavola
scegliamo prodotti senza conservanti
ricchi di omega3 poveri di grassi siamo
vegetariani siamo vegani e questo
proprio perché riconosciamo come
realmente le nostre scelte
avevo una massimo impatto sono gli
stessi e su tutto l'ambiente che ci
circonda la società stessa in cui
viviamo riconosce l'alto valore delle
dell'alimentazione
la dieta mediterranea oggi è
riconosciuta come patrimonio immateriale
dell'umanità dall'unesco
questo perché il cibo ha un grandissimo
valore che va veramente a inondare
diversi aspetti della nostra vita sempre
firebug sosteneva che il cibo è cultura
e del sentimento
proprio per questo però per questa
grande importanza che io stesso sempre
riconosciuto al cibo mi sono fatto un po
di domande per cercare di capire di
capire meglio il mondo alimentare
realtà mi sono reso conto che poi non mi
era proprio tutto così chiaro ad esempio
mi sono reso conto come in realtà oggi
ad esempio i prodotti made in italy di
cui tutti noi andiamo molto fieri
in realtà non sono propriamente quello
che ci aspettiamo ad esempio in realtà
il definire un prodotto made in italia
oggi è sufficiente che l'ultima fase
della produzione avvenga sul suolo
nazionale
ed è per questo che in realtà un terzo
di questi prodotti che consumiamo arriva
dalle parti più disparate del mondo lo
conosciamo neanche noi la reale origine
delle materie prime
un'altra storia che mi ha dato molto
effetto è quella di alcune patate che
avevo acquistato qualche tempo fa erano
un nuovo prodotto estremamente
innovativo erano delle patate
ricchissimo di selenio che è un minerale
fondamentale nella nostra dieta
queste questo nuovo prodotto permetteva
di assumere la stessa quantità di
selenio per cui prima avremmo dovuto
mangiare quasi sette chili di patate con
soli 800 grammi di patate effettivamente
era un prodotto estremamente competitivo
dall'altro lato però mi sono mi sono
chiesto con in fondo come abitualmente
ognuno di noi assuma questo selenio in
realtà mi è stato detto che era
sufficiente mangiare 100 g di pesce e
che in realtà con una dieta equilibrata
è possibile assumere una quantità
sufficiente di selenio per avere un
buono stato di salute e che anzi sarei
dovuto fare sarei stato doveva rimanere
molto attento rispetto al quanto selenio
avrei assunto in quanto in quantità
eccessive potrebbe diventare
un prodotto pericoloso e questo nel
fatto la cattiva anzi si sta proprio qui
e che in realtà non abbiamo una
grandissima chiarezza di quello che
mangiamo ogni giorno della qualità
dell'origine e delle proprietà dei
prodotti sappiamo anche che viviamo in
un mondo che mentre certo estate la
popolazione mondiale che deve lottare
quello che cita e sono in sovrappeso
successo sono un'altra meta del mondo
che non ha neanche un pasto assicurato
ogni giorno però io in questo mio
viaggio ho cercato una buona notizia la
buona notizia credo di averla trovata
basta semplicemente provare realmente a
cambiare le cose
la ragionevolezza sosteneva don
chisciotte può essere una follia è la
cosa più folle e quella di vedere la
vita così com'è e non come dovrebbe
essere a lei cercherà una buona notizia
sono andato e non è poco probabilmente
c'è stata poca ragionevolezza cioè gli
anni settanta particolari mi sono
ritrovato in in un piccolo paesino che
gode nel massachusetts negli stati uniti
qui un gruppo di giovani biologi in
fondo un centro di ricerca estremamente
innovativo per l'epoca iniziarono ad
occuparsi di energie rinnovabili
iniziarono ad occuparsi di produzione
sostenibile tramite agricoltura ed
acquacoltura buona dei progetti più
interessanti e fu sviluppato da questi
ricercatori fu quello del bio shelter il
mio shelter era una una serra che doveva
rappresentare un eco sistema autonomo
rispetto all'esterno in grado di
conservare
l'energia e auto produrre cibo per gli
eventuali abitanti della serra bene
all'interno di questa serra inserirono
delle grandissime vasche d'acqua
lo scopo di queste vasche d'acqua era
quello di accumulare il calore durante
il giorno per poi rilasciarlo durante la
notte quindi mitigare l'ambiente esterno
siccome il loro scopo per ora anche
quello di fornire una fonte alimentare
inserirono molto semplicemente
all'interno di queste grandi vasche dei
dei pesci
essendo però grandi osservatori di
quella che era anche di quella che era
la natura e di quella che è la natura
osservare che in realtà quelle vasche
con questi pesci potevano rappresentare
un terreno fertile anche se sembrerà
abbastanza folle ma poteva rappresentare
un terreno fertile per l'agricoltura e
quindi costruirono delle strutture
galleggianti in modo tale da poter
sorreggere le piante sopra queste vasche
in modo tale che le radici potessero
rimanere emerse all'interno del fluido
lì in quel momento nel 1969 nacque
l'acqua tonica l'acqua tonica e non ci
stiamo di produzione alimentare e
integrato basato sulla sinergia che si
instaura tra tre elementi diversi e cioè
i pesci i batteri e i vegetali bene il
il ciclo è relativamente semplice non è
altro che la riproposizione di quello
che è parte del ciclo dell'azoto in
natura è una tecnica di produzione
alimentare infatti che viene definita
biomimetica i pesci mangiano mangiando
ovviamente producono degli scatti
tramite la dc
questi scatti sono ricchi di ammoniaca e
questo genererebbe dei problemi per la
sopravvivenza stessa dei pesci ebbene in
acqua tonica questa ammoniaca viene
convogliata in in una seconda parte del
sistema che è quella dove ci sono i
batteri questi batteri sono dei batteri
particolare sono i batteri ed
elettrificato ri i batteri ed
elettrificato ri sono in grado di
trasformare l'ammoniaca e nitrati e
nitriti e bene cosa ci fanno di vegetali
i vegetali per crescere hanno bisogno di
alcuni nutrienti fondamentali e uno di
quelli più fondamentali sono proprio i
nitrati in questo modo che cosa
riusciamo ad ottenere otteniamo un
fertilizzante quindi che ci siamo auto
prodotti per per i nostri vegetali che
quindi possono svilupparsi possono
crescere
dall'altro lato facciamo anche sì che
però la concentrazione iniziale di azoto
che era all'interno della vasca dei
pesci si riduca e quindi l'acqua pulita
possa ritornare all'interno della vasca
chiudendo il ciclo
i benefici sono evidenti rispetto
all'agricoltura tradizionale con l'acqua
pollica produrre è possibile produrre
vegetali con il 90 per cento d'acqua in
meno rispetto all'acqua coltura
tradizionale è possibile evitare
completamente lo scarico di reflui
derivanti dall'impatto della cultura che
hanno un elevato impatto ambientale però
dall'altro lato possiamo anche ottenere
un per la stessa unità di superficie
possiamo ottenere due prodotti
commestibili pesci e vegetali avendo
quindi delle rese
di superficie che sono estremamente
interessante competitive oggi l'acqua
tonica a partire da da quell'impianto
che quindi parlato si è evoluta
moltissimo diverse università hanno
fatto ricerca e diverse aziende oggi
producono tramite l'acqua conica
l'europa stessa oggi ha investito 8
milioni di euro nella ricerca verso
l'acqua tonica i soggetti che oggi sono
coinvolti sono diciamo tre categorie
diverse
tre macro categorie la prima categoria
che quella qui sono molto legato eppure
dei contadini in pantofole sono
contadini che hanno deciso di auto
prodursi il proprio cibo direttamente in
casa loro tramite la fotonica non avendo
a disposizione ettari di terreno ma
semplicemente molta inventiva
ebbene con l'acqua tonica si può
produrre sui propri balconi possiamo
produrre sul nostro terrazzo possiamo
produrre addirittura in cucina ho visto
degli impianti costruiti direttamente
nelle cucine delle delle case dove
venivano prodotte semplicemente le
aromatiche che poi sarebbero state
utilizzate durante la preparazione dei
cibi
la comunità internazionale per l'acqua
tonica oggi conta di centinaia di
centinaia di persone che condividono
gratuitamente le loro idee sviluppano
tutti assieme diversi progetti adatti a
qualunque a qualunque persona tale che
ognuno di noi oggi 40 costruirsi il
proprio piccolo impianto una seconda
categoria
molto importante è quella che vede
coinvolte diverse persone in diverse
parti del mondo che non sono fortunate
come noi e quindi che hanno problemi
geopolitici
come guerra è piuttosto che carenza di
risorse come la terra a disposizione è
proprio qui che diverse le
organizzazioni internazionali oggi hanno
deciso di investire nell acqua tonica e
portare l'acqua tonica per dare una
nuova soluzione non alternativa e delle
opportunità il fatto che vedete sono di
un progetto che è stato portato avanti
ragazza dalla fao
inizialmente sono state individuate 100
famiglie in cui le donne si trovavano da
soli a dover portare avanti la famiglia
dover fermare i propri figli
bene la fo deciso di portare qui a
queste donne 100 impianti inizialmente
oggi sono due volte più di 300 famiglie
ed installare degli impianti di acqua
tonica sui tetti delle case di gaza
questo ha dato gli evidenti benefici a
queste persone
queste persone oggi hanno guadagnato in
salute possono finalmente mangiare che
hanno un pasto appunto ogni sera per i
loro figli ma dall'altro atti dell'atto
anche delle nuove opportunità di di
quello che l empowerment della persona
che oggi ha l'opportunità ad esempio di
vendere prodotti a gaza in cui
sicuramente hanno ben altri problemi
rispetto a quello che è la coltivazione
normalmente ma un'altra categoria è
quella commerciale qui abbiamo diverse
aziende che hanno visto nell'acqua
qualità un'ottima opportunità di
investimento oggi
ed è così che in diverse città del mondo
ma anche negli emirati arabi lì in zona
completamente deserti che sono stati
installati degli impianti
in modo tale da offrire prodotti freschi
la tua vera prima impensabile produrli
esistono dei supermercati che hanno sul
tetto delle norme serre dove vengono
prodotti i pesci e vegetali che vengono
poi commercianti direttamente al piano
inferiore
questo ovviamente va incontro a quella
che è la nostra necessità di cui parlavo
all'inizio di conoscere quello che
stiamo mangiando e di ridurre tutte le i
chilometri percorsi dal cibo per
arrivare a noi
dall'altro lato offre anche grandissime
opportunità lavorative e sostenibili
nonché offrire anche una nuova vita a
alla città rispetto ai testi ad esempio
i supermercati piuttosto che alle aree
industriali dismesse che oggi stanno
pian pianino ritrovati tornando a vivere
e sono città come chicago ma anche città
come londra e zurigo che oggi hanno
deciso di utilizzare questi sistemi
il mio viaggio all'interno della
compagnia è stato un viaggio molto
personale non molto interessante da cui
in realtà ho imparato tantissime cose ho
conosciuto una bellissima realtà che
oggi effettivamente può offrirci un
alternativa è una speranza
ho conosciuto imprenditori visionari che
immaginano città in cui tutti i testi
saranno completamente ricoperti di serve
produttive ma ho anche incontrato
giovani e meno giovani condividere con
me esperienze e aspettative rispetto al
futuro
ho anche capito però realmente
finalmente che cos'è la sostenibilità
l'ho capito che la sostenibilità erano
proprio tutte queste persone con le loro
azioni
erano queste piccole azioni di questi
grandi sognatori
che hanno cercato di vedere il mondo in
un modo diverso la sostenibilità però e
alluminio che oggi quel quel pomodoro
che cresce nel centro di londra e viene
consumato direttamente la sostenibilità
però è anche un bambino che oggi a new
york nel pieno centro di new york può
vedere uno zucchino nascere sono quelle
donne di gaza che oggi possono dare da
mangiare ai loro figli la sostenibilità
però possiamo anche essere noi la
sostenibilità potremmo essere noi se
fossimo capaci di perdere un po di
quella ragionevolezza e vedere realmente
il mondo per come lo vorremmo non per
come per come lo vorremmo per noi ma per
come lo vorremmo per i nostri familiari
per i nostri amici e per i nostri figli
perché credo che alla fine il mondo non
abbia bisogno che dei nostri sogni
grazie